we'll see how it goes
we will get together and discuss
to vanilla and
now it's a great pleasure to introduce
who is going to tell us about defensive
complexity
in revolutionary answer well thank you
very much it's a pleasure
to be here and what i want to do today
is talk about a pro
really talk about a problem rather than
a solution it's a problem that i think
biologists could benefit enormously from
the help of computer scientists and
computer science
just if they haven't completely solved
it already might
find extremely interesting to think
about so um
this is going to talk about sort of this
problem in understanding immune systems
we'll come to that uh one of the things
that's kind of surprised me here in a
very pleasant way is the degree to which
the evolution of evolvability has kind
of come to the fore
is something that people are very
interested in i've seen a bunch of
common themes there a bunch of
interesting mechanisms and
it's gotten me excited about that that's
definitely one of the things i'm taking
back
to seattle with me this this kind of
renewed excitement there
what i've been interested in what i'm
going to talk about today is sort of the
flip side i want to talk about the
evolution of unevolvability
and in particular how do you how does
one
species make it difficult for another to
evolve so in biology we we
spent a lot of time thinking about uh
how do you win evolutionary arms races
and sort of the red queen
um the kind of red queen dynamics are
our sort of standard way of thinking
about evolutionary arms or issues each
species
tries to evolve faster to keep ahead of
the other one you have to run as fast as
you can simply to
stand still and there so there's a
tremendous amount of
work that's been done on looking at the
dynamics of these kinds of
co-evolutionary
interactions and and looking at how you
win an arms race
there's been very little work uh done on
on
a second aspect the other way to win an
evolutionary arms race instead of being
a fast runner is to find a way to
force your competitor to evolve slowly
and so that's what i want to explore
today
and talk about a little bit
like a lot of great ideas in biology
and game theory and economics and so
forth i think this this one really
as best as i can tell can be tracked at
least back to
to john nash john nash was
in the 1950s very interested in the arms
race and
this probably i'd be curious if this is
kind of part of the
story that computer scientists all know
when they think about these things
or whether nash's contributions are are
less well known um there's but anyway
i'll tell i'll tell the story briefly
nash was very concerned with the race
between code makers and
and code breakers it was a between in
ciphering and deciphering this is a very
pressing issue for national security
it was just a few years after uh turing
and the enigma machine at bletchley park
shown here and
and so on and what nash was interested
in was you know
exploring the mathematics underlying
encryption i feel a little silly saying
this to computer scientists who know
these things much better
but um but you know he nash wanted to
know
can it you know can anybody any code be
cracked and how and
could one make an un uncrackable code
and if so how do you make an uncrackable
code and so
in the 1950s um nash worked through the
mathematics of all of this
and then sent a remarkable series of
letters to the national security agency
um explaining his discoveries and so
here's
they were just declassified last year
and so here's the start of
one of his letters and you can kind of
see
you kind of imagine what it would be
like to receive a letter like this as
many pages long with
schematic diagrams of machines and and
so forth
um and so in this he explores the
problem of how hard is it to
crack any code and he writes something
that um
given my knowledge of the history is i
think quite remarkable for 1955.
he says you know so he's interested in
this code cracking
uh problem and um and he realizes that
actually this can be made arbitrarily
hard he says for all sufficiently
complex types of deciphering
especially where the instructions given
by different portions of the key
interact complexly with each other in
determination the ultimate effects on
the
ciphering the mean key computational
length increases exponentially
with the length of the key so that's
1955 and then
the you know the other the other part of
the story that i've that i very much
like is that then he sees
you know immediately where this is going
to go um in terms of the co-evolutionary
arms race
he says the cyphers become more
sophisticated um
the game of cipher breaking by skilled
teams etc
should become a thing of the past
because you can make these
uh codes exponentially hard to break um
it you know the the arms race between
deciphering and deciphering is going to
grind to a halt with a decisive win for
the incipiers
so he sent this to the national security
agency
and they you know read through it uh
concluded his system didn't meet their
necessary security requirements
informed him that the reply is written
and they're not interested in
further coordination so at the time it
wasn't properly
um appreciated but i think it's a it's a
it's a deep insight and i'd love to hear
you know in the questions about uh more
of the history
of the other ideas that were floating
around at the time um
what i think you know fundamentally to
try to capture what it was you're saying
this is this idea that i'm going to call
defensive complexity for now
the idea that a mechanism could be made
secure against subversion by using
interactability or time complexity of
learning
as a defense so if i deploy some kind of
a system
i don't have to necessarily prevent you
from accessing as long as i can prevent
you from figuring out how to operate it
effectively so we could take this into
sort of the biological domain
it's kind of rephrasing this uh in the
biological domains i'd say
uh system manifests defensive complexity
if the adversary population
will take a long time to evolve to
subvert it so now we where i was best
you know the main change here i'm
specifying a particular
learning mechanism namely evolution by
natural selection as a possible way
um as sort of the way that i want to
look at the at the adversary population
doing its learning process
um so when we go now let's let's kind of
return to uh co-evolutionary arms races
and um and and i want to focus for much
of the rest of the
the discussion on the problem of
co-evolution of hosts and pathogens and
i
you know i find it absolutely amazing
that we're actually here to have this
conversation i think it's incredible
nearly incredible that that large
long-lived multicellulars can make a
living in a world
where pathogens are able to enter their
bodies into their cells
subvert their gene expression
and so on um so how do you win you know
how do
it can't be straight red queen dynamics
that
that that uh allow us us to to keep up
in this arms race the
generation time of viruses is
approximately a hundred thousand times
ours they're
very very large population sizes we put
them under intense selection with the
immune systems
we deploy and so i want to try to ask
you know how can an immune system
possibly
work um against a adversary that has
that enormous evolutionary advantage
and so you know the of course deploying
the immune system and and
and possibly sex against parasites and
and the running an evolutionary process
sort of ongoing within the immune system
may be an important part of
of how we do this but if you kind of
think about the task that an immune
system has to face
yeah it has to has to perform in order
to function well you need to build a
system that's highly sensitive you need
to respond early to infection before the
infection does
too much damage to the self it needs
enormous breath that needs to recognize
any new pathogen it's not good enough to
have
immune systems that are responsive to
six common pathogens but you have to
be able to respond to anything that
possibly could come along things that
perhaps your parents
never saw you need learning you need to
be able to distinguish self and non-self
i think this is sort of critically
important
in making immune systems work is the
fact that
we can't encode i i believe we can't
encode genetically what is self
and non-self in any kind of obvious way
because of sexual recombination and so
we can't have uh
we can't have you know coevolution of of
a set of safe
mhc molecules say with with our own
proteins because we're going to get a
we're going to get a whole new set of
genetic variation coming in from the
other parent so
this has to be done in a learning
fashion
you need high specificity once your
immune system starts to respond things
it's
no good clearing the flu if you take out
your liver in the process
uh you need to be able to generate a
very large scale response you need sort
of massive amplification where you go
from a very small number of cells in the
repertoire up to a very large number
in an immune response you need
coordination you've got this
sort of building when you mount an
immune response you're building a
distributed tissue
in your body and that tissue needs to be
coordinated in its development
and in its behavior and function um and
ideally you know well we're wishing why
not make good use of prior experience
why not try to develop some kind of
memory this is i think an enormous
challenge to
to evolve a system that can do all these
things
and there's sort of um two and two
additional challenges
as well um that we face and one after
i've already
alluded to is we've got an immune system
has to avoid autoimmunity
immune systems can't afford false
positives and
you know strictly speaking it's not so
much that they avoid all false positives
but they
are able to turn off the immune
responses
that are launched as a result of false
positives
and at the same time immune cells have
to avoid immune systems have to avoid
subversion pathogens have evolved to
disrupt to sneak under immune
surveillance to disrupt the immune
function
and you know to use whatever mechanism
possible to try to
escape the effects of the immune system
i'll jump so there's a sort of a um
a dual challenge uh for immune function
you know the goal of the immune system
you might say is to reduce
damage from pathogens and to do that
it's got to avoid immunity on one hand
it's got to avoid subversion on the
other and the reason this is
particularly tricky
is i think these are in fundamental
opposition what you need to do to
avoid autoimmunity is you need to have
ways of shutting down
an immune reaction you can't possibly uh
prevent all false positives over the
lifetime of the organism
and so you know in order to in order to
avoid these autoimmune reactions you
need control mechanisms to disable the
immune system
of course if you want to avoid
subversion sort of the worst thing you
could do would be build in a
an off switch because that would be the
first thing that pathogens would evolve
to
to subvert um i'll just jump back here i
had those slightly out of order
so um
what i wanted to mention so there so
many vertebrate
viruses you know do try in various ways
to subvert the immune system the pox
viruses
make a living this way they
tamper with the immune regulatory
signals
they produce proteins that that
stimulate the receptor immune receptors
they
they do sort of everything you could
imagine they they affect the
the function of immune cells in their
own signal production they
produce decoy receptors that they kind
of flood the body
with decoy receptors that mop up the
signals so the signals can't reach the
true receptors
they have other chemicals that block the
cytokine receptors
they sabotage chemokine signals
in various ways they're proteins that
slice up our immune signaling molecules
so they you do all of these sorts of
things and
nevertheless they're not particularly
good at it or particularly subtle
they're you know pox viruses uh hijack
an airplane by
running into the cockpit with a hammer
and swinging it around and around and
around they don't
they don't fly the system with any kind
of uh
level of subtlety or control to actually
work you know work the system to their
own benefit they're not
as elegant say as uh some plant viruses
viroids are
in dealing with um in dealing with a
much less sophisticated plant immune
system
rna silencing system serves as a plant
immune system
and and other organisms as well but it's
conserved in plants and there are these
plant viruses
that will come in and what they do they
express a little
they express a little rna that
in double-stranded form so that triggers
the immune the
the rna silencing system that uh that
rna
is identical to a critical component of
the system itself
so they come in they express in
double-stranded form
uh an mrna that then causes the
um that causes the
the plant rna silencing system to
recognize itself as a target and disable
itself
so they're able to you know come in and
very precisely knock out the
immune function of of plant cells okay
so um just jump jump forward here so
i mean the the problem you know the
problem that i want to kind of think
about and the problem that i
would like help uh solving um
is that your communication is absolutely
essential for the immune response
um we need to be able to shut down
unwanted reactions but communication can
be subverted
as i learned yesterday there was
actually a class of problems that i
think i need to
uh you learn quite a bit more about
these sort of byzantine generals
problems that i guess if i'd
had an undergraduate education in
computer science i'd know quite well
um but i think the the immune cells
immune systems are dealing with
quite a kind of byzantine uh fault
tolerance
issue in that there is no kind of master
parliament that can vote
um and count up you know uh votes from
the various immune cells they have to
do all of their signaling in these
pairwise fashions
where some fraction of the immune cells
are quite possibly infected
with virus and therefore have their
their gene expression massively
disrupted and so are acting
essentially as traitor generals
i don't know i mean i don't know exactly
what the most useful way to kind of
leverage all of this literature
to think about the the immune problem is
but uh
but i was excited to learn about it and
and uh
you know look forward to reading up on
all of that
um let's see so
i i can uh this is just sort of a
an attempt to think about this type of
problem we could we can
uh we can think about the distinction um
between robustness
uh you know robustness would be to i'd
just
throw out a definition of preserving
phenotype or function despite
variation in environmental conditions
noise and and component failures
um i don't know if this is the best term
but that's the one we
ended up using and we kind of contrast
this to strategic robustness this is
sort of an average case
sort of a situation we contrast this
with strategic robustness
how do you preserve phenotype despite
directed attempts at sabotaging the
system this is sort of a worst case
uh robustness or tolerance
if you will and um so you know what i
want to figure out
is is how how is strategic robustness
manifested
in the immune system um so we've got
this uh
you've got this puzzle you know why
don't pathogens evolve to shut off
simply shut off immune responses and the
hypothesis i want to propose and
and hopefully i'll have a little bit of
time to discuss with you is uh
is that perhaps immune systems do this
because their control logic the the kind
of
logic of the cytokine signaling network
is
defensively complex it's sufficiently
hard that pathogens are not going to
easily be able to evolve to
exploit it i think there's some kind of
there's some kind of intriguing
biological observations that that make
one think in this direction one thing
that
that you know uh puzzles me uh quite a
bit
um is that is that uh some mice and men
diverged
100 million years ago um
and yet their cytokine signaling
networks are strongly conserved
so um the the
basic fundamental signaling pathways
between
mice and men are almost exactly the same
that is we've learned
almost everything that we've learned not
almost everything but we
we sort of the the way that we start to
try to make sense of
immune function is to look at immune
function
in mice and and through that we're able
to build up these complex
networks of different cell types
signaling by various interleukins and
other cytokines
and you know this whole structure has
been conserved
for 100 million years down two branches
so you've got 200 million years of
evolutionary divergence
on a structure that should be locked
into the most intense co-evolutionary
arms race
that we're experiencing at all you know
why don't we see
signature why don't we see change there
why don't we see strong selection
so um
yeah the the basic structural
same very very much very similar
yes so the same the structure of the
signaling networks are very much the
same to the point that we can
uh you know as a first approximation do
immunology by
uh immunology is described as uh
sometimes as the
the interaction of of mouse and
bacterium
mediated by a hypodermic needle
um and and that's you know that's how we
study
uh immune systems so we can look at uh
you know we can we can
look at selection in various ways
and the cytokine most cytokines uh show
the uh show the opposite of
selection in in the kind of ongoing
evolutionary arms race they show
purifying selection they're they're
highly conserved
um in genome-wide analysis and this is
the opposite of what we see in the
immune effector cells the cells that
actually immediately touch and mediate
and interact with and kill
and um immune systems are
are under uh strong positive selection
so we see massive sort of
uh selection for for uh for
for for divergence for difference for
for
for fixing new variants in in the sort
of the front line
cells but in terms of the the control
machinery in the back
that's all very strongly conserved and i
think that's a
that's an interesting interesting puzzle
and and it's interesting to think about
whether
uh this this kind of defensive
complexity story has something to do
with what's going on
because you can break um part of the
cytokine system one at a time well if
you break it one day if you break it one
at a time
the uh system tends to get even more
ramped up in some sense right so it's
yes so
so it's very hard to um you know it is
very much like the key i think
um would would be microphones i suspect
there um
that's one thing we need to understand
better but uh but
there's this you know time if we go back
to the the uh
whoops go back to my diagram
there you know knocking out single
interleukins
will not necessarily disable the system
it may actually amplify the ensuing
response
so so that's a that's an interesting
observation so how do we model this
story
um i'm coming at this uh
as a game theorist and maybe this isn't
the best way to to approach the problem
but i'm going to lay out one
kind of way of thinking about the
problem and and hopefully we can talk
about some others
um i want to think about this as a as a
signaling game this
there's this huge literature on
evolution of signaling games
and the basic idea is that you've got
alice gets some private information
about the world
bob has to make has to choose some
actions and so alice
picks a message from some message that
sends it to bob bob chooses actions
uh we're thinking about subversion here
and so what we want to think about now
is we want to add another player eve
who now steps in and not only eavesdrops
on the message but can actively tamper
with it and change it
to anything else that she wants to so
you can try to make game theoretic
models like this i think they're very
interesting one of the big challenges in
doing this
is trying to circumscribe the set of
things that eve is allowed to do
you know at first glance if you allow
eve to do whatever she wants
then it might be impossible for alice
and bob to communicate
so could you just say you know in the
immune system who's alice who's bob
i i will i will definitely do that i'll
definitely do that
um yeah so i just want to kind of work
through the logic of
of why i'm using the model i do and then
people may have
other very interesting ideas so we've
got alice communicating to bob
uh eve can send some kind of message uh
eve can tamper with the message
and and you know if she can do whatever
she wants we think that maybe alice and
bob can't communicate
however if eve can't figure out the ways
to manipulate the signal in order to
confuse bob
then then signaling uh may actually be
possible
despite eve's ability to interfere so
when i want to go i want to go from this
kind of situation this is a little bit
hard to model in
game theoretic context we've got three
players that already
makes things quite messy
because it refers to what you said
before why
i could not follow the arguments leading
to
why communication and now you now do
building this why communication is
necessary
what is communication and
what alice and bob represent and i
i i will tell you in a moment what else
and about what i'm going to do with
alice and bob
um communication i mean well i'll just
tell you right now
alice and bob are are you know both
components of self right these are these
are this is the immune system
uh the reason communication is necessary
is because to
generate this massive distributed tissue
that performs a
a specific function you need
coordination without without
communication very hard to
confer the necessary coordination and
function and behavior
so uh if you know if if it were possible
to simply
um send off the you know prime the
immune cells send them off
and let them all follow entirely
pre-planned
uh progression programs maybe one big
dispense with court
with coordination that doesn't seem to
be how the immune system does it
um and i think you could sort of think
about a lot of the problems that would
fall
that would arise if you couldn't
if you couldn't allow immune cells to
communicate at all after a reaction is
launched
so that's the that's why i think
communication is so important thank you
because i should have made that clear
as i was discussing all of this so what
i want to do is kind of turn this into a
signal tampering game that we can
this is a signal to every game now i
want to turn it into one that we can use
to think about the immune system
and so i want to go down to two players
and i want to think of
internal communication among the systems
of one player right so alice and bob are
both the immune system different parts
of the immune system
communicating in order to coordinate
their response
so we have two players in our signal
tampering game we've got a host
who processes information um and we've
got a pathogen
who tampers with signals and i you know
i have this kind of
schematic that i've uh used to think
about and i think about a
host you know so what happens when the
host processes information well there's
some kind of cue
in the external world or maybe you know
within the
maybe within the host's body goes
through some black box and generates a
response
um what's in the black box well usually
some kind of sensor
that is involved in detecting the cube
the sensor is going to take this
external cue and transduce it
into internal signals these might be the
cytokine signaling molecules they might
be
at various other
elements of you know say t cell
activation
and then there's some control logic that
maps from the internal set of signals
the
say concentration abstractly the
concentrations of the cytokines or
whatever
the internal signals are maps from that
to
the response so um um
the second player in my story is a
is a pathogen yes
so a computer scientist would maybe say
that control logic or the signals also
change the state of the box
right i was thinking about and and maybe
i should have something like this
i was thinking about all of so i was
thinking that the signals were the tape
so that all so that all of the state
changes are manifest
by settings to the internal signals so
the signals need not be
a sort of a one-time neural impulse
running from here to there
they could be the concentration and the
location of a particular
uh signaling molecules
that was sort of that was sort of what i
was thinking is that this wouldn't
yeah is that this was gonna um encode
the uh
the um
kind of sum of the knowledge of the
system at any given time when we
in our original crack in modeling this
with these actually were chemicals
that were evolving according to a set of
differential equations and that turned
out to be messy
and so on but that's kind of how we were
thinking about it but but tell me
i mean i i definitely want to figure out
how to i think
i think there are some nice things about
modeling it this way but it also
there's there's some distance left to go
so um so we've got a pathogen pathogen
has some kind of tampering strategy
by which it can tamper with the signals
so it can
modify the signals my idea here is is
we'll think about the pathogens not able
to
change the q the cube could be for
example the presence of the pathogen
within the
host's body can't directly impact the
sensor but can do all kinds of things to
the
to the signals uh or equivalently sort
of memory
of the of the system um and and thus
change the response generated by the
control logic
so in the game theory view of it uh you
know the the
hosts what what i allow the host to do
is to choose a controlled logic
so the host gets to choose a mapping
going from
different combinations of signals or
different levels of signals
to the response and the pathogen then
gets to choose
a tampering strategy so um
what we what i'm going to do to give the
to give the pathogen as
as much of an advantage as as as we can
to kind of represent the fact that
you know once inside viruses are able to
once inside an immune cell
control expression by that cell
but they're also able to pick up genes
from
from the host genome i'm going to make
what i call the universal constructor
assumption
simply means that the pathogen can make
any signal used by the host so it can
it can produce signals it can up or down
regulate them but
doesn't know what the signals do and
doesn't know how the
signal perturbations map to responses
so you know defective specifically
pathogens affecting the immune system
affecting the immune system yes
infecting directly i i think that may be
one particularly
um uh effective case but
certainly not necessary they could also
generate they can
infect other other tissues and generate
cytokine signals
from the genome of the host even if it's
not necessarily cytokine producing
um so i think there's i think you know
there are a number of possibilities
um okay so you know the
just just to try to fill this in a
little bit more
let's think about control logic that
maps from signal values s1
s2 and so on to some scalar response r
um and the pathogen then can
can alter each signal by up regulating
it down regulating it or
or leaving it untouched um we're going
to
we can assume that sort of you know the
hosts control system is making whatever
decisions it needs to in ways that would
be
that would be optimal if untampered with
by the pathogen so the
host is best off with the default unpred
you know default
response generated by the unprotected
signals
and then and then we can think about
you know how the response affects the
pathogen we can imagine the response to
some aspect of immune
reaction or sensitivity and so stronger
responses
correspond to higher values of you know
are
acting as more harmful to the pathogen
so what we what i could imagine is you
know r unchanged is the best for the
host
medium for the pathogen r increased is
bad for the host it's bad for the host
to be
moved away from its own default ideal
settings
but it's also bad for the pathogen the
pathogen messes up and sort of cranks up
the immune response instead of cranking
it down
our decrease is bad for the host good
for the pathogen there it's sort of
cranking down our
immune response and this is our key
insight that um
i think for me in thinking about this
was just to recognize that the control
logic
that that the host deploys um
induces a fitness landscape on which the
pathogen evolves
so i want to think to hear about this
sort of situation in which the pathogen
is evolving
uh you know tens or hundreds of
thousands times
of time faster than the host and so
you know what happens here basically the
host is going to make a single move pick
a control logic
then the pathogen will actually get to
take a whole adaptive walk
on this landscape and so what the host
is really doing is picking
uh the fitness landscape on which the
pathogen
gets to proceed yeah so is it reasonable
to think of the host response
as one dimensional you're sort of using
this letter this r
as a quantity that goes up or down and
that sounds a little bit limiting
i'm sure it's very limiting um you know
i think it's a
for i've wanted to try it as a first
pass to think about how this
um situation might work uh ultimately
um if when you think about it think
about these things in game theoretic
context i was sort of thinking well
there ultimately there's a payoff to the
host and a payoff to the pathogen and
these are scalars and
individuals are trying to maximize their
scalar payoffs and so i was thinking
you know r could be we could map payoff
space to r or something like that but
yeah sure it would be interesting to
think about
uh you know controllers that controlled
more than one axis
but but from an engineering point of
view that seems to be
one of the best strategies if you want
to send a
simple message reliably you utilize
multiple pathways and then
it's very difficult to obstruct them all
and what that corresponds to is
increasing the dimension
in which the space in which this fitness
landscape exists because that if the um
uh if you disrupt one signal you get
very little feedback
that you've accomplished anything that
some of the other signals
so i pretty much don't need to finish
the talk at this point because that's
you know this that's going to be exactly
uh my main point is by increasing the
dimensionality of the signal space you
can make this
landscape extremely hard for the
pathogen to
to evolve upon so i i think you're
saying apologies
oh that's great it means that it means
that something i said
is is making sense which is gratifying
as a speaker
um okay so you know at this point
um i throw in a bunch of machinery i'm
going to go through it quickly
and i don't think the machinery is is
fundamental to what i'm talking about
here this is example the kind of thing
you can do
um what i want to do is i want to
model this control system i'm going to
do it as a as a ternary logic
um so that we have so we can easily
think about perturbations out
perturbations down or leaving things
constant and then we can think about um
you know the host gets to specify its
control logic in
in in this uh in a form like this so if
uh
if if s1 is increased xor
s2 is not increased then then
r is increased by 2m remember that's the
worst thing for the pathogen so it's
bad for the pathogen and we can kind of
read these conditions off
um you know if uh yeah
you can read these off and so that that
logic there if you
went through and checked it builds a
fitness ramp like this
a sort of a very simple fitness
landscape that a that a pathogen could
evolve on um we could build a more
challenging fitness landscape here's
kind of a checkerboard
pattern where you start here here's the
unperturbed state
any single move by the pathogen makes
things worse for the pathogen
but it does have this target it could
reach over here
so um and so what could think about how
different
fitness landscapes
affect the rate of the evolutionary
process this is kind of fun
uh you know without knowing uh who was
going to be here or anything i
just i use these two as examples in the
paper
this fitness landscape is very easy to
learn and there's a result by viet
bergman
who's here somewhere that this
takes time proportional to the the
square
one over the square root of the
population size so it's very easy
uh to learn this whereas this
fitness landscape this checkerboard
using the result from
dan weissman and daniel fisher um
it takes time that's exponential and
this is this this is the
stochastic sequential fixation domain if
i remember right
um and uh actually if the population is
big enough you do go through with the
deterministic domain
and so on so we can take these kinds of
results from population genetics and use
them to figure out how hard it is for
the pathogen
uh to to be able to exploit this control
logic
then you know sort of the key theorem
that we could show and
in some ways this is this is sort of
obvious
based on which what you said is the host
can construct control logics that
require time that's
exponential in circuit complexity
uh for the pathogen to learn to exploit
by natural selection so
the the um the host can can deploy
arbitrarily you know sort of circuit
complexity
in the host can deploy a control logic
that takes time to the end
to learn um the proof is by construction
the easy kind instead of the
hard kind um and the basic logic
is you know where one could do any
number of different alternatives
i wanted one where there were a sort of
increasing number of
targets for the host as you increase the
dimensionality it's a i'll call it peaks
on corners
control logic here it's written out we
could go through that if we had more
time
and the idea is you know in two
dimensions
the pathogen benefits if it can get to
the corner but it has to go through
these valleys
three dimensions it would look sort of
like a rubik's cube like this and
you'd start at the center and now that
now you have to take
one two three steps well in the valley
in order to get out and as we
move up the dimensions just as you said
um
this thing becomes very very hard for a
pathogen
to traverse so this is a very you know
it uh
it's simple to actually write down the
control logic the
the sort of the length of the control
logic is uh
requires order in operators to specify
for an in-dimensional
uh system um but
it's very very hard for a pathogen to
move through so we can prove that uh
the time finite path a finite pathogen
population takes exponential time to
cross a fitness value
of n steps so that's just a little lemon
that you can
that you can show it's kind of intuitive
and um
slightly harder to show than than you'd
think it would be um
and so you know this gives us the result
we build this
in dimensional peaks on corners
control logic so you use a linear number
of gates to make this
fitness landscape that takes exponential
time and then that proves the theorem
because the theorem is
you know just simply uh says it's doable
and
and we've provided the construction so
uh
sort of to you know that's the that's
the basic intuition i think that could
probably be done more elegantly but i
wanted to just give you a sense of
the kind of way you could you can try to
model the problem formally
um where this leads me to is is to come
back to
you know one of the questions that got
me started about this uh
when i was a postdoc i had an extra year
between when my job started and
and uh and where i was kind of wrapping
up some projects and i decided to spend
the year
uh learning as much as i could about
immunology with rustomantia
and this is the main thing i learned
everything i learned in 2000 is now
wrong
but even if but even if it wasn't wrong
i've forgotten it all because i mean
immunology is spectacularly
complicated and so you know i i why
isn't theology so darn complicated
well if pre-meds could learn it
pathogens could too
so anyway that's uh um now
the other the other thing that i think
is is you know i you notice i didn't
talk at all about how defensive
complexity evolves
so i talked about the evolutionary
consequences of it but i haven't talked
about
what mechanisms lead to its evolution
and so we're
talking about the evolution of
evolvability i think it would also be
very interesting to think about the
evolution of
unevolvability um yeah so that's
that's what i have to say thank you
and that really interesting ideas though
so you showed that the diagram of alice
needs to communicate with bob in a way
that eve can't intercept or interfere
right and you show that alice can make
up a code uh
that only takes a polynomial number of
work linear
sorry the the complexity of the code
correctly right exponentially in the
number of
uh the complexity of cracking is
exponential yes and i'm lucky here
because i know
i know the learning algorithm so i don't
have to do all learning algorithms i can
use natural selection
how's paul gonna crack it right pope
needs to be in on the code too right
right well that's the other thing
how does uh yeah so how does bob crack
the code um
well you know presumably there's
advanced coordination that's possible
between alice and bob allison bubba of
course the same organism
and this is your evolution of
unevolvability problem how did
how did the immune system manage to
evolve a cycle signaling network that's
complicated enough that it's uncrackable
um yet you know it was built step by
step by step
um in order to have that complexity
functioning all the way along the way
i think that's you know i think that's
the next area that i want to try to
think about
two questions in one one is a if you if
you said you know the structure of the
system
the logic is a constant you know by and
large between mice and men
then you know the pathogens actually you
know don't need to
you know they could kind of like have
information or over
longer time steps right that's true it
doesn't have to be done within the
evolutionary time of a single individual
so
so you need to vary something within it
otherwise the pathogens will eventually
be
you know fine over over not over
a single host lifespan but rather
i think they i think they won't i think
if it's exponentially hard
it doesn't matter whether you give them
one host lifespan or a probably no
number of host lifespans either way
they're not going to crack it
um i see just another question i wonder
whether there's
you know kind of like some logic
predictions that you could go with
look at the wiring of the immune system
to to see whether
it's indeed rugged and high-dimensional
i i think that would be a great thing to
do if you could figure out how to
yes to try to actually construct what
does that fit this landscape
for perturbations on the side of guys
look like that would be
a really neat thing to check out um
haven't even tried to do that the only
predictions that we've
sort of managed to um that
uh check were simply the ones that
you'd have the cytokine signaling
network under under stabilizing
selection but the
effector molecules under positive
selection and that that turns out to be
the case
so since you used the language of
cryptography for a lot of this
there's also a further thought either
control logic
is a one-way function yes meaning that
you know
if while it desires a certain response
it doesn't know how to tamper with a
signal to produce that response
that's the generalization of the
particular
situation you're considering okay and it
could be robust against viruses or
pathogens that can evolve
more in a more sophisticated manner than
you're modeling right now i mean
maybe they don't have to make one change
at a time and get and have difficulty
getting to the corners as you have here
maybe they're capable of more
sophisticated evolution in some fashion
and it could still be
and still be secure if you had a one-way
function of a suitable
capability no i suspect i i think that
i think that's right and one of the
things i think would be very interesting
to kind of look at uh
how hard is it to evolve one way
functions how hard is it you know
basically
let's start you know i just i've just
done the consequences let's start
talking about how you actually get there
i think it can be really interesting so
it seems at least as hard to demonstrate
that
these systems have evolved to be
unevolvable as to demonstrate
evolvability which he said the point is
that
suppose that the image is very complex
and it's an obvious wave of rugged
fitness landscape from the point of the
pathogen
which it turns out makes it hard for
pathogen to correct the code
but how could you go about showing that
that is an adaptation rather than just
which is complicated right so that's
something i'm worried about
um if if it were a matter of um
i think basically one would want to look
at the consequences of perturbation so
if it were a matter of immunology being
complicated which i think is you know
should should be a null hypothesis uh in
this case if you had a
if you had a rude rube goldberg machine
uh instead of
instead of an uncrackable code it should
be that almost anything you do to it
breaks it
uh rather than uh sort of amplifying the
response
and the immune system seems to be the
other way around so that's that that's
my best
the best thing i've got so far you can
sort of see a glimmer of some
predictions but pretty tough to test
i think so yeah exactly um yeah that's
that's you know one of the things that
would be i'd like to learn more
both on the i mean you see i've just i'm
just the conduit between eric chastain
who's the computer scientist and
russ devante and the immunologist and so
i'm just
up here you know kind of making up stuff
on both sides of the aisle
i think it's a very nice idea i'm a bit
confused by how
um the communication from a to b
can be robust to mutations if it's
if the fitness landscape is so rugged so
how does how does the
system deal with that's a very good
question
um
that's a question i need to spend some
time thinking about that is a that's a
serious concern
i mean it's it's part of this evolution
of
uh unevolvability puzzle is that how
how can you have a system that can
continue to add complexity when
complexity you know with perturbations
have this
generally deleterious effect um i think
yeah i'll leave it at that because i
don't have a better answer
but but you've observed i mean with your
construction that you only
need to add a fixed number of gates into
the trading network
to make it a geometric factor
harder for the for the adversary so
that's right i mean if you have to do
fewer stuff i'd love to have a better
explanation for why those steps were
even evolutionarily easy
uh to make but
you could say that it has to be harder
for the host to evolve the system that
put the pathogen to our wooden
because of the fitness landscape which
is that any change is bad from the post
point of view whereas
half the change is good and half about
for the path
so i mean one might hope that you'd be
able to step step
yeah that that's a major concern let's
just
the post and the pathogens see different
fitness landscapes because their moves
are different
yeah are adding gates to the complexity
of the encoder
yes and the pathogens are navigating the
fitness landscape encoded
well before you set it up they were the
same they were the sis but maybe it
doesn't well i think that
um the host is at a working position the
what so what is the host what's the main
move the host needs to make just add one
more signal
and so right now you're in the center of
the hypercube and now you add one more
signal and all you've got to do is get
that signal low
right because everything else works
right and you just add in the signal so
that it interacts complexly with some of
the other signals
and has a proper level so you're you're
kind of doing these linear things you're
not doing these hard
explorations and the other thing that's
useful of course is there is individual
selection for getting this right because
you do have
you know 100 000 generations of
bacterial evolution
a viral evolution in your body and so uh
you know not only is this beneficial at
the
at the kind of lineage level but has
even been officially getting it right
yourself
christmas um i mean continue
what nick started i mean i think that
the the landscapes are different
and in fact uh i mean in some sense
the rubik's cube the the dimensional
you know the question is are most uh
most
uh most hills are really
bad you know yeah that's a good question
i know my intuitions about the geometry
of these high dimensional spaces are
terrible and so so i don't i don't even
have a guess
now now now you are talking about a
space where
every point is
so if you wanted a mechanism that
cheaply generated this
encoding strategy it seems that you want
a gene duplication to to create a copy
of an existing signal yeah
and then location away from that and
every time you moved away from it
change the sig nature of the signal that
was being used you would immediately see
an improvement because you'd be making
that's right
gradually raising these extras that's a
very nice mechanism
spikes in landscapes
okay i'm just wondering though the the
pushing of agony levels to the
host is is pushed by the selection
pressure
from the from the pathogens right so so
yes
i think you kind of like expect the host
to be like one step away
no longer no more than one step away
from
where where the you know community of
pathogens have
breached or something um you might
expect something like that yeah
there's a nice cancer suppressor analogy
i think there
it also looks like the signal
integration part would have to be
somehow
highly localized from the point of view
of the host
because if the water localized then
there would be a point which the virus
could just
kill the whole system yeah that's right
i mean i think this definitely has to be
done in a highly distributed event
that's part of why i
got quite excited about this byzantine
generals
uh story because it is so massively
delocalized
all right well thank you all very much